[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored
turmoil in Tel Aviv as Israel's prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu faces waves
of protest that threatened to bring down
his government in a world exclusive
interview the only one he's given in his
crisis Netanyahu sits down with me to
debate whether he and Israel's fragile
peace can survive this
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is tonight fighting for his
political life he's been pushing through
laws to give elected governments like
his the power to select judges critics
say it's an attack on Democracy that
threatens vital checks on his the prime
minister's power well tonight Netanyahu
sensationally suspended those plans for
a month he spoke of a dangerous Clash
that is endangering Israel's basic unity
and he said he was now prepared to
suspend pushing this legislation through
Parliament it's not clear exactly what
the new time frame will be it may just
be a few weeks in which case it may not
be the end of his process but it's some
kind of breakthrough there have been
massive protests from right across the
political divide
tens of thousands to the streets in
anger on Sunday after Netanyahu fired
his defense minister who called for this
kind of cause police and soldiers used
water cannons on demonstrators gathered
outside netanyahu's home today Israel's
biggest airport suspended flights his
workers went on strike ports shops Banks
even hospitals are now disrupted well in
a moment my world exclusive interview
with prime minister Netanyahu it's the
only one like I say he's given
throughout this turmoil
but first in the last few hours the
embattled premiere has gone on National
Television in Israel and addressed the
people of Israel after 48 hours of Total
Chaos he was criticized and not speaking
to the country all day but eventually he
did and here's some of what he said
I am aware of the increased tension that
is happening between the two parts of
the country
I am listening to the ones of many
citizens to release this tension but
there is one thing
that I am not willing to accept
there is one
minority that is willing to tear this
country into pieces
well prime minister Netanyahu was in
London over the weekend he held talks at
Downing Street with our prime minister
Rishi sunak before flying back to a
country in chaos late Saturday night or
just before he got on that plane I got a
call to go and sit down with Benjamin
Netanyahu for what turned out to be the
only interview he's given during this
crisis a genuine World exclusive
promise you've been elected six times
you're the longest serving prime
minister in Israel's history 15 years
Israel is 75 in a few weeks time and it
ought to be a time a celebration both
for you for this extraordinary Personal
Achievement and for your country but
instead Israel is in turmoil at the
moment facing what some fear could turn
out to be civil war fears of a potential
third interfada
is this your biggest challenge right now
it's a very big challenge but I I think
that the prospects for Israel are great
I think there is a lot of concern about
the Democratic judicial reform that we
want to move ahead with but people think
that it's going to uh to result in a
fissure that I don't think will last
because people will see at the end that
Israel was a democracy is a democracy
and will be even a stronger democracy
after this democratic reform so I think
I think you're right there's a lot of
tension right now I and I wish it wasn't
so but I'm quite confident that we'll
get over this uh this difficulty because
you know you have to reform things that
get ossified and in Israel what we've
had is uh the ossification of the the
the imbalance between the three branches
of government that has to be corrected
this happened in the last 20 years it's
been building up building up building up
and people say we want to correct that
and you know people who are used to one
thing don't want to correct itself
because the critics say it's not reform
it's regime change effective is what
you're trying to push through they say
that what this bill will do it'll arm
you the prime minister with the power to
appoint judges that you want and for
your government to overturn any Judgment
of the Supreme Court that you don't like
it's almost as even a one vote majority
in the knesset in other words the
Judiciary they say will be neutered and
with that the rule of law and with that
democracy itself yeah well let's take
that apart one by one the first thing
that that has to be understood is what
is a democracy democracy is majority
rule with a protection of individual
rights and to get these two things what
you have is the checks and balances
between the three branches of government
the legislative the executive and the
judicial everybody understands that in
Israel over the last 20 years that
balance has been
uh taken off the rails because the
Judiciary became not independent it's
always been independent will always be
independent it became all-powerful so it
can nullify any decision of the
parliament the knesset and it could be a
legal decision a legal uh law that's
fine but they say it's not reasonable it
doesn't exist anywhere in the Democracy
such Powers it can nullify any decision
of the government and often has it can
nullify any appointment of the
government it can intervene in military
matters it can intervene in our battle
against terrorists it can intervene in
taking gas out of the sea that causes
billions of dollars billions of dollars
I finally got it out all these things
are unacceptable but it's cool hang on
it's called checks and balances well
there is no checks and balances but the
only well actually it's the only
checking balance in Israel to the
government no no it's not in in all
democracies there's one other thing and
I'll get I'll answer your question one
by one it's important there's one other
thing that characterizes this uh the the
the Judiciary in Israel and that is that
the judges veto the appointment of
Judges they effectively select
themselves in other words that doesn't
exist in any democracy the reform that
we're dealing with right now corrects
that it allows for a balance well it
means that you can pick them no no I
can't pick them in fact it's it's it's
an even thing between the majority and
the minority the Coalition and the
opposition uh it's in in fact not that
one side can pick them but by the way in
most democracies with the exception of
Britain by the way they all all judges
are chosen by elected officials and in
Israel the discussion is so uh narrow
and so one-sided they say how could it
be the judges will be chosen by elected
officials and I say hello this is what
is being done in every democracy why why
is someone like you who's always been
such a staunch defender of an
independent Judiciary in Israel why take
a move that even some of your close
colleagues and supporters say is a step
too far in infringing on that
Independence I absolutely will always
defend the independence of the Judiciary
and the way that's achieved in all the
democracies who are in which judges are
appointed by elected officials in
America in America for example who picks
the judges the politicians the president
the politicians then have to affirm by
the way that's replicated more or less
in most of the democracies in one way or
the other well how do how are the judges
independent they're independent because
once they're there they're there either
until retirement or until life and
that's what happened in the United
States just now I mean the former
president chose some very strong
conservative judges is and the first
opportunity they're voted against them
because they're independent so the
independence of the Judiciary will
always be maintained I think that the
important thing to us that's not that's
not how people are seeing this because
they don't know the facts well they
studied the bill and they say they're
presenting it as as an autocratic move
no well they're framing it as such but
they haven't really studied them but is
what you're doing really consistent with
what you said in 2002 yes in the speech
let me remind you your exact words then
I believe that a strong independent
court allows for the existence of all
other institutions in a democracy I ask
that you show me one dictatorship one
undemocratic Society where a strong
independent court system exists there's
no such thing in places with no strong
independent court system rights cannot
be protected in fact the difference
between countries in which rights are
only on paper and those in which there
are actual rights that difference is a
strong independent Court this is the
reason that I am doing it will continue
to do everything I can to protect the
court system and make it strong and
independent I will continue to to
operate this way every time a bill comes
across my desk that could harm the
independence of Israeli courts will take
it off the table that's you 2012. and
now here you are 11 years later you're
the one putting the bill on the table
which many people on all sides of the
divide in Israel say is achieving the
exact thing you were so Keen to avoid I
stand by everything that I said an
independent Court in a a Judiciary that
is independent is something that was in
Israel and where we remain in Israel but
here's the thing in the last 10 years
the Judiciary went from being an
independent Judiciary to an all-powerful
Judiciary the balance of three the three
branches of government says that you
have to have three branches that are
balanced in Israel you have like one big
trunk the Judiciary that's what's
developed with two little Twigs on the
side that's not democracy democracy
means that every every branch of
government balances the other and that's
in Israel it's the most judicially
activist court on the planet
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no what are you every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7 p.m join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
why take a move that even some of your
close colleagues say is a step too far I
am the prime minister of Israel that's
not that's not how people are seeing
this because they don't know the facts I
think it's called checks and balances
well there is no checks and balances
isn't that slightly patronizing prime
minister how did you feel about Donald
Trump having dinner with Kanye West but
it wasn't a legal Invasion wasn't it did
you take sides too much with Trump
basilos mushridge cool for the
Palestinian town of awara to be wiped
out that's just a fact
[Music]
thank you thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored a
world exclusive interview with Israel's
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu next I
pressed him on whether he'll back down
people would rather in Israel it seems
judging by these Mass protests hundreds
of thousands of people out on the
streets protesting every weekend now for
nearly three months you've got generals
Scholars entrepreneurs former heads of
Mossad some of your closest political
allies have come out and attacked this
and said this is a Judicial coup made by
the majority in order to grab power away
and not give Israelis the Protections in
law they're entitled to reservist
fighter pilots refused to attend a
training exercise this week joined by
650 members of the IDF Special Forces
command this is Uncharted Territory for
Israel and you've got Army general staff
senior military officials who believe
this is now imperiling the security of
Israel and you've always positioned
yourself I know this because you've told
me yourself before as Israel's Mr
security well let's let's again if you'd
allow me to answer the question okay so
the first thing is I think balancing the
judicial uh having the judges not select
themselves which is what this bill is
about is not only does not only uh
weaken democracy it strengthens
democracy because in all other
democracies and all other democracies
with the exception of the UK and there
may be one more exception the judges do
not choose themselves the elected
officials do and that's what this bill
does and I think it's right on the other
hand there is one consideration that the
critics and the opponents of this
judicial reform uh uh raise and I think
it's a valid concern and that is you
want to go from one extreme to the
center you don't you don't want a
pendulum to swing to the other side
where the us at our Parliament can
nullify any decision of the Supreme
Court and I think that requires a
balance I agree with that so it has to
be so you are going to rain back then on
this case propose yes I said that how
significantly well I said that there's
not going to be uh this unlimited power
when you want to restrain unlimited
power you don't go and give the
parliament unlimited power over the
court that's what they say this
character does I explained very clearly
that as far as I'm concerned that will
not happen so I think you need to reach
the the happy center now the other thing
is look I don't want the Army you know
look
I think a lot of people go to these
demonstrations they're patriotic
Israelis they want the good of the
country but a lot of them don't actually
know the details of the bills just like
I just described they don't even know
that the leaders of the opposition that
are not going to these demonstrations
they themselves argue that the court the
way we select judges should be changed
they themselves did it before the
election all these people protesting
just don't get it many many of them
don't many of them isn't that slightly
patronizing prime minister no I don't
think to tell your own people who are
protesting in hundreds I didn't say that
all of them don't I mean they just don't
understand well listen you have to see
the mainstream media in Israel that is
going on this like a huge huge huge
propaganda campaign well the added
complication for you is that you of
course are still going through an
ongoing trial that is suspended while
you're prime minister for corruption and
bribery not suspended at all it's going
on all the time so it's going on it's
going on and in fact it's unraveling the
charges the uh the charges that were put
before me were ridiculous and they're
just unraveling in the court you're
discovering things like prosecutorial
intimidation of witnesses the
blackmailing of witnesses changing uh
tampering with them but here's the point
so all of that is coming out and brother
you would agree you would be dealt with
in the trial the judges that are going
to decide this case have already been
selected they will not be affected
here's the point I was going to make is
twofold one the Attorney General Gali
baharav miara says you broken the law
by directly involving yourself in an
overhaul of Judiciary when you're facing
an ongoing corruption trial she said it
was illegal and tainted by conflict of
interest that's completely false I
maintain the same conflict of interest
restraints and I'm abiding by every
consideration that my case is not going
to be affected by this legal reform one
IO but what happened to insist I'm the
prime minister of Israel Israel is going
through the most acute crisis in many
years
uh you yourself said how important it is
to say that the prime minister of Israel
cannot deal with something to try to
bring a resolution to this crisis cannot
speak about it cannot try to resolve
this issue cannot take care of the
security of the country which you
yourself say maybe uh maybe uh impacted
by this this is this is absurd if it was
a if it was an opposition leader who was
in power who was going through a
corruption and bribery trial I don't
think you'd have the same view I think
you would say I think you'd say there's
a clear conflict of interest here I'd
say no there isn't because the trial or
my legal proceedings are completely
unaffected by the this so the Attorney
General I mean if
if the statement is that you've broken
the law you're saying as prime minister
of Israel the Attorney General is wrong
about the law of course I'm saying they
said it openly and it's not a question
we have a disagreement on that in fact
that's going to be brought up uh in
court proceedings I think it's wrong I
think I as prime minister of Israel have
a responsibility to see if I can somehow
bring a conclusion to this impasse
somehow bring a resolution so we have
responsible judicial democratic reform
and at the same time Keep the Country
together who's going to do that if not
the Prime Minister your point is that
the Judiciary has got too much power
but what you want to do and this is
again from your critics and there are a
lot of them and like again to repeat
they're not just people on the
opposition this is you know the voices
across the across the Divide here on
this they say what you're pushing for is
a form of autocratic rule where the one
remaining check-in balance on your power
as prime minister is just evaporated and
you also ultimately can then determine
judge selection you can determine what
laws you pass or don't pass you become
the overriding autocratic leader as they
have in many countries where there are
genuine autocracies of the kind that you
talked about in 2012 in that speech you
keep repeating these uh these shiblets
and these these absurdities I made
Israel the most liberal country
among the most liberal countries on the
planet I liberalize its economy it
turned it from a straight jacketed
socialist economy to a free market
economy that benefited the entire people
I brought in investments into the Arab
sector more than all the previous
governments combined uh very proud of
the fact that the leader of the gay cell
and the likud my party I nominated to be
the speaker of the knesset the third
highest position in the country and he
was elected not because he's gay he was
elected because he's very good but
that's the liberal position that I've
always espoused and espoused now to try
to paint me as some third world autocrat
is ridiculous I believe in the balance
I'm a classic Democrat with a small deer
I don't want to get into trouble with my
American friends but I'm I'm a a classic
believer in the balance between the
three branches of government that's what
ensures democracy and it's been thrown
off balance in Israel we have to bring
it back it will not give any power I do
not select what happens when I do not
select the judges in fact they'll be
selected by uh by a composite committee
it's not important right now but the
majorities minorities they all have
their place in there so this is complete
falsehood what are the concessions
you're going to make from the current
bill to appease those who say what
you're doing is taking it from one
extreme Pendulum In Your Eyes the most
the most important thing the most
important thing is indeed to restrain
the power of the parliament to strike
down any decisions that the Supreme
Court makes I think the Supreme Court
deserves its place under the sun its
powers but it just has to be there are
no checks and balances right now in
Supreme Court power so you want to get
some checks and balances on that but you
don't want to eliminate checks and
balances on the uh but you want to stop
the Supreme Court from interfering in
any no no no no it's called against
basic laws which form the Constitutional
framework if you will you don't have a
Constitution Day no well the the Supreme
Court argues that we do already or the
the founder the Supreme former Supreme
Court president said that the basic laws
that have been enacted form a
constitutional framework so that those
in any case those laws in my opinion
have to be protected uh the Supreme
Court can't challenge them but it can
challenge other laws and the question is
what is the majority that is required in
the Supreme Court to strike down the law
that's I won't get into the the weeds
what they're going to do surely the
Supreme Court they will try and strike
down this so so what do you do as a
prime minister that wants to do this if
the Supreme Court exercises what it
believes to be its right to strike down
your bill well I think that there's a
it's never happened before that the the
Supreme Court strikes down basic law
this is a basic law and I don't think
they're about to do it and uh they never
had such a direct attack on their
Authority it's not well then the
question is should they be able to to
judge that to you know that's a question
it seems that the people of Israel who
are protesting every week and all these
eminent people who are commenting about
this they prefer the current situation
to one where the power moves to the
Prime Minister it always it doesn't move
to the Prime Minister that's got nothing
to do with it the Prime Minister gets no
two politicians yeah well then you have
to ask yourself
if that were the case I don't see any
democracy that has such extreme powers
of the Supreme Court as in Israel
there's no such democracy so are they
not democracies are they dictatorships
of course not they're perfect when you
are trying to take some power away from
any branch of government and in this
case from the Judiciary they don't want
to take it away right now you have a
situation where 15 unelected members of
the Supreme Court effectively govern
Israel they can decide things that
affect our military our economy our
Foreign Relations our battle with
terrorism is that right is that
Democratic no it's not Democratic you
want to correct it Israel is democratic
in the sense that you vote for a
government but when you vote for a
government you want that government to
govern right now the powers of that
government to govern are severely
restricted by a supreme court that has
more Powers than any other in any other
democracy on Earth you don't say that
those other democracies are somehow
tainted are somehow not Democratic
because they've they have a better
balance of power and trying to balance
it is difficult got you that you can see
how difficult it is right I don't deny
it and I understand the concerns of
those who are generally generally
worried about the future of Israel but
so am I and I would not let Israel
become less Democratic I wanted to be
more you've always been a politician
strikes me who's got an instinct for
what the people are thinking you must be
aware the scale of this is like nothing
you've ever had to deal with in any of
your terms of office any Israeli Prime
Minister you this is unprecedented for
you and there comes a point when if
you're just going to keep pushing up
against this gigantic ever-growing Hill
of opposition including you know members
of your own government who said they
should we should stop this and negotiate
what is your response to that well you
know I was the first one to call foreign
even though I was in a curious position
because they told me you can't deal with
the the actual uh workings of the bill
so I didn't I actually didn't but I did
call on the opposition to join the
Coalition the government to discuss uh
reaching some kind of cop compromise and
I've called for three months and they
haven't come so you ask yourself and
when they say let's halt it I said you
just wasted three months why didn't you
come in and talk get into the room start
saying saying what your concerns are
like the ones you raised you will uh our
people will give their responses we can
I think we can figure out a middle way
that will be I think Successful by the
way I still hope that will happen
remember that the bill that is now in in
Parliament as we speak is uh is is one
component just one component it really
does only with the selection but you
know how big it is blown you went to see
Richie soon like British prime minister
and in their readout of your meeting it
spoke about the desire to save Israeli
democracy curiosity in yours I'll read
the exact word he said the importance of
upholding the Democratic Values underpin
our relationship including in the
proposed judicial reforms in Israel but
in in the statement from your office
didn't mention that why well because we
spoke for about an hour and the the the
Prime Minister indeed raised that issue
where prime minister Rishi it was uh
there's a debate in my in my team
whether it was 45 seconds or 47 seconds
out of the hour so yes he did raise it
you're quite right I don't deny it but I
think it's sort of it's become a
perfunctory thing you sort of have to
say it because people are oppressing
they're BDS people they're oppressing it
they're uh you know it's become a
political hot potato in Israel so uh the
the the opents have their supporters
here and they're pressing on the various
governments I understand that and look
people don't necessarily get into the
details of it but I do and the American
president has also said the same thing
Joe Biden yes he's also said that to you
yeah sure I spoke to him the other day
on the phone what did he say to you well
first of all we spoke about Iran of
course and I'll come to that and a lot
and uh but he raised that and I assured
him what I assured you that Israel was
Will and all is and will remain a
democracy it's a worrying time for
Israel with America because For the
First Time In polling history a majority
of Democrats in America now have more
sympathy for Palestinians than they do
for Israelis it's been 11 Point swing in
the last year alone that must concern
you and what also must concern you more
people aged 18 to 29 now view more
sympathy with Palestinians than they do
Israelis what's your response to that
well I I think I've looked at other
polls but you can never
you can never deny the the the the the
alliance between Israel and America is
takes the majority of Americans uh to
support Israel and they do they do
consistently that's going to concern you
hasn't it that Paul you know you look at
it and you say one thing uh you know
America is changing not Visa V Israel
America is changing Visa via America but
one of the reasons people have often
said that well yeah America is changing
fees of the America and therefore it
changes vis-a-vis Israel but I think the
main bulk of American of the American
public by the way across the political
Spectrum a wide wide uh birth of the
political Spectrum support Israel
because they see Israel as but not
representing not Democrats right but not
Democrat supporters and nor the young
ones 18 to 29 well there's there there's
a question of where that goes and
whether this pendulum doesn't swing back
you know one of the reasons is they they
cite a lot of them apparently your very
close relationship with Donald Trump
they think that you really pivoted to
him you described him as the greatest
friend Israel's ever I had in the White
House I said Israel had no greater
friend than the White House that's true
because he did some very good things he
moved the embassy to Jerusalem recognize
Jerusalem as our Capital recognize our
sovereignty in the Golan Heights and
went out of this disastrous the Iran
deal nuclear deal that would have paved
Iran's path with gold to nuclear weapons
so yes I appreciate it but I I always
approached American Presidents whether
it's uh did you take sides too much with
Trump not at all I never took signs
you're lying yourself too much I didn't
align myself with anyone I didn't come
in as a as a Republican or a Democrat I
came in as an Israeli and I have close
friends
among both sides of the aisle Joe Biden
with whom I often disagree by the way
someone disagreed with Trump too I tried
to tell them we should go to well he
wasn't happy when you when you tweeted
your congratulations to President Biden
winning the election maybe not but what
I was but he was extremely on if you
don't mind me I don't want to use a
profanity in front of you but he uh he
was heard on type saying that it was the
ultimate betrayal he hadn't spoken to
you since and bleep him he said about
you he then added BB is BB Bibi didn't
want to make peace never did right well
I did actually uh with his help we made
a breakthrough of Peace the Abraham
Accords with four Arab states it's a
turning point in history and if I came
back it's to do two things came back
into office because as you know it's not
walking in a Rose Garden to be the prime
minister of Israel at any time and
especially this time the reason I came
back is to do two things one block Iran
Iran's quest for nuclear weapons that
aims to destroy my country and threaten
every other country and the second thing
is to expand the historic Abraham
Accords the Peace Accords which and and
the Arab Israeli conflict and I believe
that I can do both and that's what I'm
here for but look I've dealt with
president have you spoken to Donald
Trump since since then he wrote me a
note what did he say
you congratulated me on my victory did I
yeah so have you made peace have you
spoken on the phone I didn't never made
War I mean he might be back in the white
house I've always look I have to tell
you I I have Joe Biden has been a
personal friend for over 40 years and
I've disagreed with him Donald Trump has
been a great friend and I've often
disagreed with him uh not often but
sometimes and the same happened with
other American Presidents I represent
the people of Israel a people who for
three thousand years actually 3 500
years is trying to survive and revive
itself in our ancient Homeland and we
did it doesn't go without problems as
you can see it doesn't grow without
debate Israel is fiercely Democratic
Fierce debates but I believe that we
have that my mission is to assure that
Israel is sufficiently strong militarily
economically diplomatically to defend
itself against the likes of Iran how did
you feel when one would wipe us off the
plan when it comes around one moment how
did you feel about Donald Trump having
dinner with Kanye West and the white
supremacist Nick
I think it's a big mistake it's wrong
it's wrong from every point of view how
damaging is it when someone with Kanye
West's following
suddenly seems to go Rogue anti-semitic
in the way that he did
my father was a great historian and a
story of anti-Semitism and goes back
about 2500 years as a sort of a doctrine
that keeps changing but basically people
say there's trouble in the world I want
to blame the Jews we have a setback here
or a setback there blame the Jews the
Communists say the Jews are the
capitalists the capitalists say the Jews
are the Communists blame the Jews so you
know that's a deep-seated pattern it
should not be continents it should not
be accepted it should be rebuked and
condemned and that's what I do and I
don't care I don't care where it comes
from or from whom
thank you
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to this special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored a world
exclusive interview with Benjamin
Netanyahu Israel's prime minister who
right now is fighting for his political
life amid the worst crisis that Israel
has seen in modern times in a moment
we'll debate whether he can survive
those ways of protest but first I talked
to him about Ukraine Iran and the
explosive remarks a member of his
government made about the Palestinian
people
let's talk about Ukraine briefly if we
may I interviewed Governor Ron DeSantis
the Florida governor a few days ago and
he said that Vladimir Putin is a war
criminal and should be held account for
his crimes do you share that view
well I think that I share the view that
Ukraine the Ukraine war is a horrible
horrible uh tragedy that it should be
if I can do anything to help stop it I
will and I'll I'll refrain from saying
more because I might be in a position
might be in a position to help stop it
one day have you been asked I know you
were asked at the start to try and
mediate perhaps have you been asked
again
I haven't been asked officially
but I received unofficial approaches
from
supposedly from both sides I don't want
to say more than that at the time I
wasn't the Prime Minister I said there's
one prime minister at the time and I'm
not going to jump in and if the
opportunity
arises where there's a realistic chance
that I can help stop this tragedy this
horror
horror there's no other word then I'll
do it but it wasn't a legal Invasion
wasn't it I mean it broke every
International it's not the question the
question is where is the uh you know
what is it that you can do uh to to stop
this harm and you know as long as
there's a glimmer of a chance
that I can I'll keep that
live or alive
Iran now can enrich uranium to 84 Purity
which clearly is a dangerous situation
not leastful Israel
they might see what they perceive to be
from what they've read and heard and
unchecked Israel government packed with
what many people view as extremists as a
as a threat as a threat to them
so okay well let me just put that too
because people have said that well they
say a lot of silly things I mean this is
silly Israel is a no this has come from
Israelis who fear that that may send the
wrong message too well I think that's
nonsense I mean I think all Israelis are
united in seeing the danger of a nuclear
Iran all Israelis understand that at
least I understand that it's my
responsibility as the leader of the one
and only Jewish state which Iran's calls
for its Annihilation to do everything in
our power to stop it and Iran should
know that I
uh and Israel will do everything we can
to stop it it's got nothing to do with
the composition of the government it's
got everything to do with the
composition of our history and the fact
that they're calling for our destruction
Rishi sunak uh said again in the readout
from your meeting our governments will
continue to work closely together to
push back against aggression from Iran
and manage the risk of nuclear
proliferation but in reality what can
someone like Rishi sunak on behalf of
Britain do to help you in this situation
I think first of all it's important to
say it I think it's important also to
apply economic pressures uh I I think
the combination of crippling economic
sanctions and a credible military threat
can hold back Iran's nuclear Ambitions I
don't think without a credible military
threat you're not going to stop Iran
just as you the only thing that stopped
Saddam Hussein was a credible military
action on our part the only thing that
stopped
Syria
or rather
from developing nuclear weapons is a
credible military action on our part
Gaddafi feared a credible military
action on the part of the U.S so he gave
up his nuclear weapons North Korea
didn't so it has now nuclear weapons it
can cover half of Asia and very soon
perhaps the United States
Iran is 50 times more dangerous than
North Korea and we must do everything
and I must do everything to prevent it
from having nuclear weapons what is
required from the International
Community
sanctions strong sanctions from the
United States and from Israel
a credible military threat final
question prime minister there have been
88 Palestinians and 15 Israelis killed
so far this year it's the highest rate
of deaths in two decades many are saying
that a lot of this is down to incendiary
rhetoric from some of your right-wing
members of your government and they
particularly cite bezel smotherstridge
who earlier had called for the
segregation and Maternity Ward so Arab
and Jewish newborns would be separated
at Birth he's now in charge of the Civil
administration of the Occupy West Bank
last week he said who was the first
Palestinian King what language do the
Palestinians have was there ever a
Palestinian currency is there a
Palestinian history or culture nothing
there is no such thing as a Palestinian
people
that's not helpful to anything is it uh
I think that there are a lot of
statements that he made previously that
he uh
walked away from and somebody said to
her were not accurate in any case
they're part of my government but
they're part of my government and I uh I
decide policy distance yourself from
comments like that there are many
comments anybody call for the
Palestinian town of awara to be white of
course of course not of course
totally unacceptable he collected he
corrected
wait a minute be fair to him about I
don't know if it was 20 minutes later or
uh 30 minutes later or whatever or a few
hours later he said
I was misunderstood that's not what I
meant we don't believe he doesn't
believe it by the way I know him uh got
to work with him now a few months we
don't believe in Collective punishment I
go after the terrorists I go after those
who support the terrorists but I don't
believe in Collective punishment I also
think that you should know that the the
rise of Palestinian terrorism and is the
consequences the the fatalities that
you're talking about actually happened
in the previous government it doubled
the number of shooting incidents Drive
downs and other things that are involved
in terrorism came from the Palestinian
side and the weakness that we have here
is the weakness of the Palestinian
Authority that doesn't send its Security
Forces to stop the terrorists and
therefore we have to do it and what we
are trying to do right now is calm
things down put a if you will uh
put some kind of mechanism in place that
we're trying to do with the Palestinian
Authority and with others to stop the
violence members of your government
saying stuff like that is unbelievably
in Century well that comment on that
Village is absolutely right and he
walked away from it very quickly but his
comments saying there's no such thing as
Palestinians well he has that view uh I
think do you have that v no I think I
think there wasn't a Palestinian people
in the 19th century clearly
I think it galvanized their National
Consciousness galvanized in the 20th
century and the question is will it hold
or into the future that's something that
has to be seen uh but I I think they're
there they're they're definitely you
know living among us and we have to live
among them the problem we have with them
is that they say you're not going to
live among us the problem the reason
this conflict persists now for a hundred
years is because the Palestinians led by
irresponsible leaders are resolutely
opposed to a Jewish state in any
boundary so it doesn't make it no one
succeeded previous governments very
left-wing government generous
governments you know unbelievably
concessionary governments they gave
everything nothing helped because they
are not interested in a territorial
resolution they're interested in the
dissolution of the one and only Jews so
far this year so far this year six times
as many Palestinians have died as
Israelis that's just a fact well do you
want to compare what happened in uh I'm
not just saying this year you want to
come you want to compare other conflicts
uh include Global I'm saying this
historical yeah well because what
happens is that they start shooting the
Israelis uh they have we go after the
terrorists the terrorists are hide
inside terrorist strongholds and to get
to them we have to fight other
terrorists most of them by the way are
combatants that is terrorists who are
who have been hit but in the crossfire
that is there I wouldn't judge the
justice of a battle by the number of
casualties on either side because you'd
be in very very shaky historical ground
uh and you know that very well I know
you've got to go to get a plan uh you're
on Tick Tock I'm on Tick Tock yeah a lot
of calls now for people to ban Tick Tock
what's your view for Israel and will you
come off it no no I haven't looked into
it though
you're not worried about the Chinese
well harvesting data for you and all the
Israelis who use tick tock well I'll
tell you what since you raise it I'll
look into it thank you prime minister
good to see you thank you thank you for
your time thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
welcome back to Perry's organizer
joining me now is U.S lawyer Alan
dershowitz and columnist for the
guardian Jonathan Friedland uh Jonathan
let me start with you also you're at a
terrific piece for the Jewish Chronicle
about this uh some of which I have to
say I I used a frame some of my
questions for Benjamin Netanyahu it was
so beautifully phrased so thank you for
that um
your position on Miss is that you you
believe I think you both believe that
there's a comparison to be made here
with Donald Trump Jonathan you go first
because I think it's not a favorable
comparison that you would draw
yeah I mean I think there is a
comparison to be drawn
um in the sense of somebody who has a
total disregard
for Democratic norms and in this case
it's being played out in the sense of
those things which make a democracy
function it isn't just a matter of The
Ballot Box and whoever gets the most
votes is then in total control a liberal
democracy exists with yes majority uh
Power in for example a parliament but
then a whole lot of breaks as you used
the phrase in your questions to the uh
to the Prime Minister you talk about
checks and balances Israel is really
quite unusual again you brought this out
in the interview it really has none I
mean there isn't a written Constitution
again you said that there isn't a second
chamber in Parliament and therefore the
only break the only restraint on a prime
minister in the Israeli system it's very
very unusual is this body the Supreme
Court so in Netanyahu was telling you
that you know it's got out of control
it's got far too much that's partly a
function of a system where nobody else
can put a break on the Prime Minister uh
accept that court now in the United
States there were all kinds of breaks
and restraints on Donald Trump a written
Constitution courts that he couldn't
control a senate a house all kinds of
things Israel doesn't have that so even
if they've got the same impulses
Netanyahu is in some ways much more
dangerous because Israel allows a prime
minister if they want to they're bent on
doing what he's doing now
to concentrate all power in their own
hands right Alan dershowitz I mean that
that seemed to me my take away from the
interview was this just seemed to me he
he has it in his head that the Judiciary
Supreme Court in particular in Israel
has gone too far to the left and is now
being deliberately restrictive and
obstructive to his government which is
to the right but he also acknowledged
that he doesn't want the pendulum to
swing right the other way which is how
many people are categorizing this they
think that what he's trying to do really
is say right you've got too much control
I'm seizing all control and that is the
behavior of an autocrat
I think both sides have exaggerated
their claims uh I think the Judiciary in
Israel has gone a bit too far my oldest
friends in Israel are Benjamin Netanyahu
I've known for 50 years in ahood Barack
who engineered the judicial Revolution
who I've known for 55 years and there's
a reasonable argument that both sides
have gone too far which is why we need a
compromise I think it's absolutely
essential that the parties get together
sit down and resolve this and there are
ways of resolving it I've written a
series of Articles the Supreme Court
should have power and final word over
basic civil liberties human rights
minority rights but it should not have
the final word over who serves in in the
government by the way your previous
guest says there are no checks and
balances in Israel that is totally and
completely wrong there have been six
elections in the last what five years or
five elections that's the ultimate check
and balance in a democracy through the
the people out if you don't like them if
you can't maintain your government
together very very few countries in the
world have judicial review Israel may
have more judicial review than any other
country in the world but I'm on the side
of the Israeli Supreme Court but I do
think that both sides have points to
make this is not an issue that generally
results in worldwide attention judicial
reform when's the last time we've had
demonstrations over additional reform
judicial reform is a surrogate for
opposition to the right wing elements in
the government and I understand that
I've met with smutridge I've met with
Ben gevir and there is good reason for
protesting them but if the same judicial
reforms had been advocated by people at
the center of the party there wouldn't
be such demonstrations should be
judicial reforms but not as Extreme as
either side right Jonathan I mean the
other part of this which cannot be
overlooked I raise this with the prime
minister is that he's himself currently
still undergoing a criminal trial for
bribery and Corruption and of course
people are saying well of course he
wants to control the Judiciary because
that means he can then control what may
or may not happen to him or indeed
Future Leaders who get themselves into
similar positions yes
yeah this is the crucial point I mean I
I think you know great respect for
Professor dershowitz's analysis there
although I did like his position more in
January when he was saying if I were in
Israel I'd be at those at those protests
that's because this isn't a debate in a
uh legal seminar room among you know
Harvard Law students this and it's
understood by the people who are heading
onto the streets this isn't just some
abstract matter of refining a few tweaks
to the precise Arrangements of the
Israeli Constitution this is a power
grab it's happening now because uh
Benjamin Netanyahu is on trial for three
very serious counts of corruption that
where if you were convicted he would end
up in jail and he does not want to go to
jail and therefore he wants to have some
control over the judges of the Supreme
Court who would hear if it came to it
his appeal so this is pretty naked I'd
be people there no comparison is perfect
but people have said this is as if
enduring Watergate Richard Nixon just
decided to tear up the Constitution and
make the Supreme Court something which
he whose members he could decide and in
his interview with you just now he
Netanyahu tried to uh suggest somehow
that this would be not him it would be
politicians it would be his appointees
the could member sort of hacks who would
sit on the committee that would do his
bidding and put in if they got their way
judges who would do his bidding so this
is serious business those people on the
streets would not be there if this was
just an abstract theoretical debate
they're there because they understand
what's at risk under their country okay
and then finally just quickly um this
polls very worrying polls American
support from Democrats in 18 to 29
moving away from Israel now to
Palestinians
well first of all that's been a movement
of young people for a long time but I
want to talk to the comparison between
Trump and Netanyahu I wrote a new book
called get Trump which is about efforts
to try to prevent Trump from running for
office by illegally and improperly going
after him by weaponizing the criminal
justice system there have been efforts
to do the same thing with Netanyahu
these three charges against him are
totally phony charges and they're
designed to remove him from office and
nothing in the judicial reform would
make it easier to win the case his case
will be won in front of trial judges
that were appointed years and years ago
and that serve for life so I think there
are analogies there are analogies
because a lot of people in Israel want
to get Netanyahu and a lot of people in
the United States want to get Trump but
that's where the analogies okay stop I
think we ought to think about these on
their merits and not try to personalize
them because I think these these issues
of judicial reform are serious and that
we should sit down and resolve them with
both sides getting an opportunity to
make their points well I suspect that's
exactly what's now going to happen
because I think Benjamin Netanyahu my
sense was he's been pretty shocked by
the reaction and the scale of it and I
think you're above all else he's proven
himself to be a Survivor and a pragmatic
politician so I suspect he's going to
get around a table and water this down
but for now anadosia it's Jonathan thank
you both very much indeed for joining me
I appreciate it
well that's it for me uh extraordinary
interview in extraordinary times uh
Benjamin Netanyahu the leader of Israel
facing the biggest challenge of his
entire career that's it for me whatever
you're up to keep it unsensitive good
night
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 p.m join me just do it
well that one too
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored